But
Excuse me.
The conversation I've had with those
people is okay, so how do how do you buy
a coffee with it? How do you buy a pair
of shoes with it? How do I buy a a plane
ticket with it? I'm standing in the
terminal airport. I need to get from
Chicago to St. Louis. Um
it's an emergency. I can't wait an hour
to get on the flight. I can't I I can
barely wait the 10 minutes. How do I
transact? Oh, lightning. Well, I'm
sorry. No, lightning doesn't work.
Uh
what 23% of the time
I remember Peter Harpending did a really
good article. It's on gajumaru.io
and I think qpq.swiss
about exactly this. That lightning
doesn't just fail at $100. It gets more
and more failures the further up the the
value chain you get. So, when you get to
an airline ticket last minute It's not
going through. It's not going through.
Full stop.
>> There's no way.
And all the demos with lightning are
done for micro payments for a good
reason. Um
Mhm. The reality is it's a massively
intermediated system. The Gini index is
0.97. I say all these things. I say,
look, you know, one is absolute
monopoly. It's that's that's how bad
lightning is.